the fight for the future of our country  is taking place among younger and  younger audiences the radicals are  pushing gender ideology to  kindergarteners and demanding lesbian  toy kisses in pixar cartoons by the time  that students get to high school they  very likely will have had upwards of a  decade of leftist indoctrination  indoctrination especially these days  that is becoming unsettlingly sexual in  nature according to recent gallup  polling just under 21  of gen z identify as queer that is twice  the rate of millennials five times the  rate as gen xers eight times the rate of  the baby boomers 26 times the rate of  the silent generation seems hard to  argue that this massive expansion of the  alphabet coalition is the result of some  normal biological process seems to me  that those numbers suggest that this is  a social phenomenon